[Music]
should i juggle a bit
i've had a long term love affair with
lemons
[Music]
this is a world of colors intensity
condiments tahini hummus muhammad
everything together
so it's totally informal the opposite of
french
cooking right this
beautiful smoke that's all flavor
the one thing i really don't like is a
boring meal they want to go ah
what was that
[Music]
people think i can't cook middle eastern
i don't know how to make my vegetables
taste delicious
i hope to show you that you can cook
those things and you can do it really
really well
vegetables have an incredible ability to
be played with
it a bit soak flavors grill these
carrots
is very instagrammable
[Music]
this is a very crucial moment when you
add ice water
it aerates the hummus makes it even
smoother lighter
and i'm adding comfy garlic i can't
possibly envisage a
dish without garlic that's just not
natural
[Music]
eggplants take on flavors like nothing
else
there's something meaty about them this
dish it happens to be vegan
i challenge any meat eater to say it's
not perfect
i always like to keep the last bit for
myself
[Music]
i grew up in the heart of the middle
east where there's quite a lot of
confrontation going on
and i found over the years that food is
really an international language
it has this incredible ability to bring
people together
i want you to be able to go into the
kitchen without the stress
i want you to be able to sit around a
table
share a meal with your family and
friends and be really proud of what
you've created
i'm yotamo tulengi and this is my master
class
[Music]
you